I think if the ad messaging is good if
it's worthwhile if it serves a purpose
and if it's engaging and interesting i
think it's okay i think there's a lot of
bad advertising i would say oh let's
let's ban the bad advertising and just
find somebody who can go through with a
red pencil and just kill all the bad ads
but you can't do that I don't think that
I think that the bad advertising gets
filtered out by the consumer they just
don't they don't buy things that they
don't need and they don't pay attention
to ads that are not directed towards
them and I don't answer that the most
important question in the English
language which is what's in it for me I
mean if that if what we do doesn't
answer that question then we don't win
whether we're selling something or in
the workplace we don't win unless we can
answer what's in it for you so I I don't
think that yeah we are certainly a
consumer-driven economy and loose in
America we are I don't know that's good
i've tried to temper our consumerism
personally but that's what makes our
economy work and that's what makes jobs
for people and that's what makes us a
successful country so i don't know how
much you want to tamper with that
advertising is a big part of capitalism
and what makes this country powerful so
you